thank you it's great to be here and I'm
gonna be talking about something that is
been of great interest to me I hope it
would be interesting to you I've studied
the brain for many years using
technology and recently I've been struck
by how technology seems to be altering
our lives and wondered how it's altering
our brains so to try to get at that
question it brings up issues of
creativity and technology and we know
it's accelerating the pace of life
that's reducing the time for thoughtful
reflection but ironically the internet
and all this new technology was
developed to free up time to help us
become more thoughtful and creative now
to get a better idea of some of these
issues we've heard about how Google
might be making a stupid in at UCLA we
wanted to ask what really is going on
with Google is it making us smart is it
making us stupid
so we raised a bit of money got some
collaborators together there and we
devised an experiment to try to
understand how search is affecting our
brains now I wanted to know what does
the brain look like the first time it
searches online so I had to recruit
people who had never searched online I
quickly learned I couldn't recruit them
online and so we've got people like this
congratulations you're the last person
on earth to get an email account and
then after looking for some time we
found some older people about a dozen of
them who we called Internet naive and we
match them up with another dozen who
were internet savvy mostly women
well-educated as far as we could tell
the only way that groups differed was
according to their computer experience
now to do this experiment we used an MRI
scanner and those of you who have been
in the narrow tube no it's too narrow to
get a computer in there so we use these
special goggles to show the volunteers
either a bar and we said concentrate on
it so we could factor out what the brain
does when it pays attention then we had
another control task reading a simulated
book page and then we had these
simulated internet pages and there was a
little key
or next to their side so they could
operate a mouse and and here's what we
found here we see the breath the
computer adding up what's happening in
the brain the colored area show you
where your brain is working the first if
you're Internet naive and you're reading
a book page so there's a little bit of
activity in the visual area of the brain
memory verbal areas not too surprising
so here are Internet naive people
searching online for the first time look
the same I was a little bit disappointed
with the experiment
so we went on we took the internet savvy
people we had them search online excuse
me to read a book page looked the same
and here was a big payoff when we saw
the internet savvy people searching
online there was more than two fold
increased activity in the brain so
here's your brain reading a book and
here's your brain on Google or Bing
so the headlines where Google is making
us smart but we really didn't show that
we just found that if you had prior
experience it's activating your brain
now part two of the experiment we took
the internet naive people and we trained
them we said for an hour day we want you
to search online and we found there were
significant increases in brain activity
in the front part of the brain the
thinking part of the brain that makes
decisions holds in short-term memory the
kinds of functions we know we need to
use to search online so here's what I
think's happening in these kinds of
experiments initially when we're
presented with an unusual task we don't
know what to do and there's not much
brain activity once we figure out a
strategy we see a surge of
neurocircuitry activation but once the
task becomes routine we see a decrease
in activity representing brain
efficiency so what we're seeing today is
a big booming business of brain fitness
and a lot of companies are developing
different types of ways to train the
brain we're doing this at UCLA with our
computer science department because we
think we can do it and we think we can
innovate we can combine physical
training with mental training so that we
can improve brain efficiency and brain
health as we age in fact we've done
experiments where we put people on
healthy lifestyle programs including
brain training memory training
physical training and we find that it
does activate certain parts of the brain
that are important for memory so what
about this question is technology
weakening our memory if you ask people
how many phone numbers they remember
today it's probably a lot fewer than
before and so there's this concern that
somehow the PDA is shrinking your
hippocampus and my answer to that is we
need to pick and choose what we learn in
our biological memories so names and
faces if you see somebody's face you
don't want to look up what their name is
in your PDA and so you want to use
memory techniques but for pretty much
everything else you can look that up we
also have to remember that just playing
video games can train our brain surgeons
who play video games make fewer errors
in the operating room so next time you
have to have surgery ask the surgeon how
how many hours a day is playing World of
Warcraft that may have an impact on your
health we also know offline brain
training whether it's psychotherapy or
anything else can alter neuro circuits
so the key today is finding balance what
I call a brain gap between what's going
on in the brain of digital natives and
digital immigrants and teach older
people how to use the technology and
younger people how to use their
face-to-face human contact skills which
are tremendously powerful now I just
want it to comment on the Future brain
because we're looking forward in this
conference today and we know there's a
lot of technology developing on brain
computer interface and we can put
sensors on a person's head and they can
operate a computer so in the future
instead of wearing a Bluetooth what I
predict is you'll be wearing a headband
or maybe an earpiece and you'll think a
thought and it will be transmitted
wirelessly to your friend so if you want
to have coffee they'll hear that thought
on their PDA they'll meet you and you
can sip your cappuccino you don't even
have to talk you can read each other's
minds but in terms of spam you may have
to wear tinfoil hats to protect yourself
as you walk down the street so that's
one scenario and I really believe this
is feasible in their near future we have
the technology another question will the
computers actually read our minds in
terms of privacy and I think there's a
possibility of that a carnegie mellon
mellon university they are developing
experiment
where computers can read person's
thoughts so what about this question is
search the end of memory or the
opportunity of collective wisdom I don't
think it's the end of memory but I think
it's altering the way we use our memory
becoming searchers and gatherers we're
not becoming memorizers but what we have
is a huge opportunity instead of our
limited biological memory stores we have
an external hard drive that we can
optimize the World Wide Web now how will
it affect collective wisdom depends on
how we use it we could spend a lot of
time using it in a way that is
destructive to our humanity and our
wisdom or we can expand it thank you
very much for your attention okay that
was those fascinating thank you